A MISTER DODD WE ARE GOING TO
START THIS APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO YOU
COULD COME UP YOU HAVE.
TO DO PASS BILLS SB SIXTY TWO
MAY I ANYWAY I'LL JUST.
READ THIS FROM WE GET CALLED
ORDER SO LET'S GET RIGHT TO
MISTER DODD I HAVE A QUORUM IF
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR SB.
SIXTY TWO AS A THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND THEN THANK YOU FOR WAIVING
PRESENTATION ON YOUR ONE TWO
THREE FOUR SUSPENSE BILLS AND
THEN WE'LL HEAR YOU.
WITH SB FOUR FOUR TWO I MAY
BREAK INTO YOU IF WE GET A
QUORUM.
BUT PLEASE PROCEED OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS THE FISCAL COMMITTEE.
IF TESTIMONY COULD BE LIMITED TO
FISCAL IMPLICATIONS THAT WOULD
BE APPRECIATED.
AND WE DO HAVE A QUORUM HOLD ON
WE'RE GONNA CALL THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO BY PORTANTINO HERE
BATES.
BATES HERE BRADFORD HELL HELL
HERE JONES WE CAL SKI HERE WE
CASKEY HERE.
SO SINCE WE HAVE A QUORUM MISTER
DON I'M JUST GONNA READ A COUPLE
THINGS WE HAVE EIGHTY ONE BILLS
TO HEAR TODAY SIX OF WHICH ARE
PASS.
RECOMMENDATIONS THE REMAINING
BILLS ARE ALL SUSPENSE ITEMS THE
FOLLOWING BILLS.
ARE ON FILE BUT THEY WERE
APPROVED THIS TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT
SOMEONE WILL PORT DIRECTLY TO
THE FLOOR -- SB TWO SIX SEVEN BY
MISTER WALK CASKEY SB TWO SEVEN
ONE BY MR WIENER SB FOUR HUNDRED
BY MR ON BERGEN SB.
THREE FOUR THIRTY SIX MISS HER
TADO -- ARE ALL ARE IN THAT
CATEGORY -- I'VE MENTIONED
PLEASE KEEP.
ALL OF OUR TESTIMONY TO FISCAL
IF POSSIBLE.
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE A FORM AND
MISTER DODD PLEASE TELL US ABOUT
SB.
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SB SIXTY TWO ADDRESSES
TWO SUNSETS IN LAWS PERTAINING.
TO ENDANGERED SPECIES SB SIXTY
TWO EXTENSIVE SENSE THAT
CONCERNING PROTECTIONS AGAINST
AN ACCIDENTAL TAKE OF ENDANGERED
SPECIES.
TAX IT'LL TAKE PROVISIONS WERE
ORIGINALLY ENACTED IN LAW.
NUMEROUS TIMES IN THERE BEEN NO
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE STATUTE.
THE BILL AS A REQUIREMENT THAT
THE FARMERS WHO ACTUALLY TAKE
THE SHE REPORT THE EVENT
DEFICIENT WILDLIFE.
DFW IS NOT REQUIRED TO DO
ANYTHING OTHER THAN COLLECT THE
INFORMATION.
SECOND THE BILL ALSO ELIMINATES
A SUNSET OF THE SAFE HARBOR
AGREEMENT PROGRAM ACT.
THESE CHANGES HAVE MINIMAL
FISCAL IMPACT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE IN BOTH
CHANGES WILL ENHANCE PROTECTION
OF ENDANGERED SPECIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING NO WELL KRAMER'S THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION.
SB SIX YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
PROGRAMS THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO
FARMERS AND RANCHERS AS PART OF
THE CALIFORNIA ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT WITH ONLY MINOR
COSTS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE IN THE COLLECTION
OF THE NEW REPORTS THAT WILL BE
REQUIRED FOR OUR MEMBERS AND WE
WOULD URGE.
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
YES MISTER CHAIR CHRIS MCKINLEY
ON BEHALF OF HUMBLE MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES.
AS WELL AS MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THE CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION AND WE SUPPORT THE
BILL ON POLICY GROUNDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
VALERIE NEAR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ALSO
LEARNED SUPPORT AND URGE YOU TO
PASS IT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE
IN THIS GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS STILL LEONA
TERROR WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I DON'T HAVE A FILE ON
THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU -- ANY QUESTIONS.
MR CASKEY IT DOESN'T IMPROVE THE
MATTER WE HAVE A MOTION MR DI
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ACTUALLY
ASK YOUR MY FAVORITE CLOTHES.
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS GO UP --
WE WILL CALL THE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO IRON
TINO I'D BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD HILL.
HILL AYE JONES WE CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
THE CURRENT LOTUS FORTY ZERO
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THAT OPEN FOR
THOSE MEMBERS WHO WERE AT THE
POLICE OFFICERS MEMORIAL TO ADD
ON LATER.
WITH THAT IF YOU COULD GO INTO
SB FOUR FOUR TWO ON STATE PARKS
PERMITS YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SB FOUR FOUR TWO WOULD
PROVIDE A LIMITED.
EXCEPTION EXCEPTION TO PERMIT
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS AND
QUALIFIED INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION TO COMMERCIALIZE
DISCOVERIES THEY CAME FROM
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS.
SB FOUR FOUR TWO WOULD AUTHORIZE
DIRECTOR TO ISSUE A
COMMERCIALIZATION PERMIT.
IN CERTAIN SPECIFIED
CIRCUMSTANCES AND COLLECT
APPLICATION AND PERMIT FEES.
THESE FEES WOULD BE DEPOSITED
THE STATE PARKS AND RECREATION
FIED.
THIS BILL WILL HAVE MINOR COSTS
IN MAY GENERATE SPECIAL FUND
REVENUE FOR THE STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
BUSINESSES.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRED MEMBERS
JASON MURPHY ON BEHALF
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA -- PROUD
TO BE HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT AS A CO AUTHOR THIS BILL
WE DO APPRECIATE -- THE
POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITIES DEVELOP
COMMERCIALIZE DISCOVERIES WITH
STATE PARKS AND HERE ANSWERING
QUESTIONS MAY HAVE HAVE A
COLLEAGUE HERE WITH ME FOR THE
DAVIS CAMPUS WHO BROUGHT THIS
ISSUE TO OUR ATTENTION.
A GOOD MORNING MEDIATOR LOPEZ
FIGUEROA RELATIONS DIRECTOR UC
DAVIS -- HERE IN SUPPORT AND TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION SIR FILE FILE
THE FATHER THE QUESTIONS FOR MR
DONE.
WE HAVE A MOTION MISTER DODD I
SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MAKE CLOTHES.
SPECS LAST FOREVER.
HERE SO GOOD -- WITH THAT WILL
CALL THE MOTION.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD HELLO.
HILL AYE JONES CASKEY HI BECAUSE
HE AYE.
ALL RIGHT WELL FORTY ZERO WILL
HOLD THAT ON GERMAN WE HAVE MORE
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR WAITING ON YOUR
OTHERS SO IS APPRECIATED.
IS THAT ARE YOU ARE ONLY AUTHOR
HERE [inaudible]
WHERE IS?
THE SIX YES.
THEY'RE PRESENTING MR HUESO.
WHETHER IT IS ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT [inaudible]
LET'S GO.
SO MISTER HILL WILL PRESENT SB
FIVE OH SIX ON BEHALF OF MR
HUESO.
WHICH IS ALSO A DO PASS WITH
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES IT'S AN
ENERGY CRISIS LITIGATION.
PLEASE MOVE FORWARD MR HELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS -- I'D LIKE TO PRESENT
SB -- FIVE FIVE OH SIX WHICH
REINSTATES THE AUTHORITY OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO REPRESENT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND TO
EXERCISE THE POWERS OF THE NOW
DEFUNCT ELECTRICITY OVERSIGHT
BOARD.
IN THE LITIGATION RELATED TO THE
TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND TWO
ENERGY CRISIS.
BY STATUTE IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX WITH THE INTENT TO ADDRESS
ISSUES ARISING FROM THE
RESTRUCTURED.
ELECTRICITY MARKETS IN
CALIFORNIA STATUTE AT TASH THE
IT IF YOU'LL BE WITH THE POWERS
TO INVESTIGATE ANY MATTER
RELATED TO THE ELECTRICITY
MARKETS TO PROTECT THE INTERESTS
OF THE STATE'S CONSUMERS IT WAS
DE FUNDED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT HOWEVER WITH THE HE HE'LL
BE WAS A PARTY TO NUMEROUS.
LEADING LITIGATION CASES RELATED
TO THE TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND
TWO ENERGY CRISIS.
STATUTE HAS EXTENDED THE
AUTHORITY TO REPRESENT THE
INTERESTS THIS WILL REINSTATE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S AUTHORITY
TO CONTINUE TO REPRESENT THESE
INTERESTS I HAVE A WITNESS TO
TESTIFY MARIO DE BERNARDO.
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ON
BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OF YEAR BUT SERRA.
MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME'S MARIO
DIBERNARDO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF YOUR BUT
SERRA WHO'S PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS BILL.
IT'S A PRETTY SIMPLE BUILD WILL --
WE'VE HAD THIS AUTHORITY TO
REPRESENT THE DEFUNCT
ELECTRICITY OVERSIGHT BOARD FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW.
THESE ENERGY CRISIS CASES ARE
STILL PENDING -- FOR IT HAS NO
FIRM DEADLINES WHERE THEY NEED
TO HEAR THESE CASES AND SO --
THAT'S ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS
WHY THEY ARE -- STILL PENDING
THE BILL AUTHORIZES.
US TO CONTINUE REPRESENTING.
THE STATE IN THESE MATTERS AND
THERE ARE SEVERAL BILLION
DOLLARS STILL -- TO CALIFORNIA --
STAKEHOLDERS IN THESE CASES SO
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND THE OTHERS SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
FINANCE NO FILE NO FILE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS SO THE
QUESTION IS BATES.
ANALYSIS JUST MENTIONS THE FACT
THAT MAYBE AN URGENCY CALLS
MIGHT BE REQUIRED.
AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
AUTHORITY LAPSED BACK N I THINK
THEY'RE SAYING TWENTY EIGHTEEN
I'M SURPRISED IT DIDN'T COME UP
IN THE POLICY COMMITTEE THAT
SOMEONE MIGHT ABOUT STOOD.
BEFORE THE YEAR'S END YEAH
BECAUSE THE OTHER ONE I HAVEN'T
SEEN THE NEED AT THIS POINT --
THEY JUST SOMETHING DOWN TO TO
MAYBE GET CLARIFIED.
SO THAT DOESN'T GET STOPPED ON
THE FLOOR AND MAKE SURE THAT IT
DOES YEAH SPECIALLY SINCE IT HAS
SAID IF NECESSARY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL DO IT ANYWAY.
WITH THAT ONE NOTATION AND LET
MR HUESO WE HAVE A MOTION LET MR
WAY SHOULD KNOW OF THE QUESTION
AND PERHAPS YOU MAY WANT TO
AMENDED.
FIRSTLY -- YOUR CLOTHES RESPECT
AS ROAD AWESOME -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
HE MADE A MOTION. TO STRIKE OUT
YOU MENTION YOU MISS AN OPTION.
I DON'T PAY ATTENTION BUT I KNOW
ALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO I AM
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I BECAUSE KEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE. FIVE ZERO WILL
PUT THAT ON CALL -- I DON'T SEE
ANY OTHER AUTHORS HERE SO WE'LL
GO UP TO MISTER WHITE KOWSKI.
WHO HAS NICELY WAY PRESENTATION
ON HIS FOR SUSPENSE BILLS SB
THIRTEEN ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS?
ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FINANCE THE FILE NO
FILE SEEING NO QUESTIONS FOR
MISTER WHITE KOWSKI -- WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT BILL WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
MR BORDER US WALKS IN ON CUE AND
HAS A DO PASS I BELIEVE WHERE IS
THAT HIDING.
THERE IT IS.
MR VARGAS IF YOU'RE A READY TO
COME PRESENT.
SB.
FOUR OH TWO WE WILL TAKE IT.
THIS IS A SUPPORT.
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES WITH A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR.
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU I HAVE A GERMAN
PORTANTINO AND AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- I AM HERE TODAY --
TO ALLERGIC TO THE FACT THAT
THIS STATUS BEFORE TWO IS A FIVE
YEAR EXTENSION AND INYO COUNTY
TO VENTURE TRAIL PILOT PROGRAM --
I THINK -- I WILL PASS ON THE
SUBSTANCE OF IT BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE IS
NO FISCAL IMPACT -- WHATSOEVER
ON THIS -- ON THIS PROGRAM --
ESPECIALLY GIVEN ITS PILOTS
STATUS WHICH IS A MERE EXTENSION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THE CARD FOR A AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS BEFORE -- TO A MODEL
PRESENTATION.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MERION
WARMER DID HALF OF RURAL
COUNTIES FOR INYO COUNTY
REQUESTING YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AMY GRANTED ON
BEHALF OF THE OFF ROAD VEHICLE
LEGISLATIVE COALITION AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
THIS FINANCE HAVE A FILE NO FILE
FILE IS THERE ANY QUESTIONS.
HAVE A MOTION NO QUESTIONS
SELECT TO CLOSE.
BERKELEY A REQUEST TO YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR US TO PROCEED TO THE
FLOOR.
THANK YOU I WE HAVE A MOTION
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO AYE
BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES I WE CAL
SKI [inaudible]
WHAT COUNTS [inaudible]
OKAY.
HE WILL KEEP THAT BILL ON CALL.
IT HAS FOUR VOTES RIGHT NOW AND
WAIT FOR MISTER BRADFORD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SINCE.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TO WITH
NO OTHER AUTHORS WILL MOVE TO
WHICH MR Y. CASKEY SECOND BILL
SB.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT CHIEF CLIMATE
RESILIENCY OFFICER IS THERE ANY
SUPPORTERS.
RICHARD MEMBERS GREG COOK WAS A
NO THE CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY
IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS ANY
OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE -- ANY
QUESTIONS NOBODY WANTS TO GROW
MISTER WHITE KOWSKI ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO QUESTIONS THAT BUILT
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
SB -- FIVE EIGHTEEN STRIKEOUTS
CAM PUBLIC RECORDS COURT COSTS --
SIR SUPPORTER.
AND A POSER.
FILE FILE NO FILE SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB FIVE EIGHTEEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
MYSTERY COUNTIES SB FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE A UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
IS THERE ANY SUPPORT.
SURE ANY OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE FILE NO FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE BUT WE'VE DONE MISTER
DODD SIXTY TWO WILL MOVE ON SB
ONE NINETY FIVE AFTER DOT ON
FIRE SAFETY.
DEFENSIBLE SPACE PROGRAMS HAS
THEIR SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION -- FILE FILE NO FILE
ON ONE NINETY SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ONE NINETY
ORDER SUSPENSE.
SB TWO OH FOR MISTER DODD STATE
WATER PARK PROJECT CONTRACTS TO
ANYBODY HERE TO SUPPORT -- TO
FOR TWO OPPOSED -- TO FOR
FINANCING FILE NO FILE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB WO OH FOUR WILL GO TO
SUSPEND SAYS B..
TWO OH NINE MISTER DODD
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE WARNING
CENTER.
IS THERE SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS CREEK C<c.cyan> PROBES</c>
INTO THE CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
SURE OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
THE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AND NO QUESTIONS SB
TWO OH NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MR DRUGS FINAL BILL SB THREE
FIFTY TWO AN ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
LICENSES IS THERE SUPPORT.
IS OUR OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE
FILE NO FILE SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB.
THREE FIFTY TWO HOLDOVERS.
MOVING TO MS GALGIANI IS WHO
WAVE PRESENTATION ON HER BILLS
SB -- ONE THIRTY EMERGENCY FIRE
SIREN WARNING SYSTEMS.
THEIR SUPPORT.
MR OPPOSITION SIR FILE FILE NO
FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ONE THIRTY WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE DOCTOR PAN AS WALKED
INTO THE ROOM.
WE WILL GO DOWN TO HIS SB. FIVE
FORTY THREE ON HAD A CABS THIS
IS A DO PASSED WITH SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES DOCTOR PAN.
AND SO PLEASE START ON SB FIVE
FORTY THREE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS
DR FAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSER STRICTLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ALL RIGHT WE'LL
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO AYE
IMPORTANT TO KNOW AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD HILL.
HILL AYE JONES JONES I WE CAL
SKI.
WE CAO SKI I ALL RIGHT FIVE ZERO
THAT'LL GO ON CALL WE'RE WAITING
FOR MR BRADFORD.
I SEE MISS HER TADO.
WHO'S HERE THAT IS A SUSPEND
BOTH OF YOUR BILLS ARE SUSPENSE
ITEMS I YOU WANT TO PRESENT.
ONE IS A ARE YOU WAVING PRESENT
TO YOU CAN WAY PRESENTATION ON
BOTH OF THEM ARE YOU CAN PRESENT.
THE G. WAY PRESENTATION ON ONE
BUT DID NOT WAVE ON THE OTHER.
SO YOU WANT TO PRESENT THAT ONE
OKAY PLEASE PROCEED.
SB -- FIVE FIVE NINE TADO.
AND TELL US ABOUT SB.
FIVE FIVE NINE GOOD MORNING MR
TURN MEMBERS -- TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT SB.
FIVE FIVE NINE SB FIVE FIVE NINE
AIMS TO ADDRESS THE NEED TO
RESTORE WATER SUPPLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS BOTH -- IN
CRITICAL NEED OF WATER.
AND IN NEED OF THE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ADEQUATELY
DELIVER.
IT TO LOCAL COMMUNITIESAND THE
LOCAL ECONOMY FOR MY DISTRICT.
ALTHOUGH THE FRANKLIN CANALIS
FEDERALLY OWNED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT LONG AGO HANDED
. FOR THE
CANAL BE AND ALSO THE BILL TO
REFLECT NEW COST ESTIMATES AND
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME ALEX BARRON
WHO.
REPRESENTS A FRONT WATER
AUTHORITY TO GO OVER THE COST OF
THE BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I VOTE.
THE MORNING I'LL JUST MAKE A FEW
QUICK COMMENTS HI MY NAME IS
ALEX DURING IN THE GOVERNMENT
FAIRS AND COMMUNICATIONS MANAGER
FOR FRANCE WATER AUTHORITY --
THANKS FOR HAVING US HERE
DIFFERENT CURRENT NOW AS SENATOR
HER TRY TO SET IS A LOCALLY
FUNDED PROJECT THE USERS WHO
FUNDED THE CANAL AND PAY FOR ITS
ON GOING ACTIVE -- MAINTENANCE
AND CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATIONS
OF PAY MORE THAN A BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS TO MAINTAINING CONSTRUCT
THE FACILITY.
AT FOUR HUNDRED MILLIONDOLLARS
IN SB FIVE FIVE NINE WAS AN
EARLY ESTIMATE THAT WE HAD TO
RESTORE THE FACILITY OF THE FULL
CANAL -- AND THAT WAS FOR THE
FULL CAPACITY RESTORATION THE
SELECT THE PROJECT WE HAVE
INSTEAD FOCUS IS ON THE THE MOST
CRITICAL NEED THE WORST SUBSIDED
OR IN THE CANAL -- AND WE EXPECT
THAT TO BE LOWER THAN FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION.
SO WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
CENTER HER TITLE AND HER STAFF
TO REFINE THAT NUMBER THE BILL
KNOWING THAT IT IS NOT A PRECISE
NUMBER AND WE NOW HAVE A WHAT WE
THINK MIGHT BE.
POTENTIALLY MORE PRECISE NUMBER
AND WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH OUR
FEDERAL REPRESENTATIVES AND
LOCAL USERS TO SECURE BOTH
FEDERAL AND LOCAL CRUSHERS SO WE
HAVE A CONSORTIUM OF LOCAL USERS
AS WELL AS AN ONGOING WORK WITH
OUR FEDERAL REPRESENTATIVES.
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM THANKS.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MERION
WARMER DAM A BITE ON BEHALF OF
RURAL COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBINSON WAS CHARTER INTO YOU ON
IN SUPPORT OF THE COUNTIES OF
FRESNO TULARE AND CURRENT.
FRAZIER ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE IS THERE FILE.
UP FINANCE CURRENTLY DOESN'T
HAVE A AND APPROVED POSITION ON
THIS BILL THAT WOULD NOTE THAT
CURRENTLY THE BILL APPROPRIATES
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES.
OF THE DEPARTMENT HAD NOT
PROVIDED AN ESTIMATE OF THE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BILL AT THE TIME OF THIS
ANALYSIS.
BUT WE ESTIMATE THAT TO ANY
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS WOULD BE
MINOR AND OBSERVE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I KNOW THERE'S ALSO --
PERHAPS OF DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE ON THIS PROJECT
AND OBVIOUSLY ANYTHING TO REDUCE
COSTS.
GOING FORWARD THAT CONVERSATIONS
VERY IMPORTANT -- TO DO THAT --
YOU KNOW.
I APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
AND MISTER TYLER THIS IS A
SUSPENSE ITEM DOES ANYBODY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE THIS
MATTERS BEFORE SEPT TWO AND AND
AND THE REQUEST SO WE'LL BE
DEALING WITH ON THE BUDGET SIDE.
RIGHT THANK YOU SO THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS BUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NUMBER
YEAH -- OBVIOUSLY WHEN WE IT'S
GOING TO GO TO SUSPENSE THE DAY --
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S A LOT
OF CRITICAL MASS AND SUPPORT WE
KNOW THIS IMPORTANT FOR YOUR
DISTRICT IN.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD AND YOU KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AFTER OCE
DISTRICT AND YOU'RE DOING THAT
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS BILL
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE TODAY AND
THE CONVERSATION WILL CONTINUE
TOMORROW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT.
AND DID I SEE SENATOR WIENER.
SENATOR WIENER PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR WAIVING
PRESENTATION ON OF YOUR BILLS SB
ONE SIX SIX HAS A TO PASS AND
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES -- SO
PLEASE PROCEED AND TELL US ABOUT
TO SP.
ONE SIXTY SIX HAPPY TO DO SO
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR WORKING WITH US IN THIS
BUILDING FOR THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
BY THIS -- BILL -- IS DESIGNED
TO MAKE IT EASIER FASTER AND
MORE EFFICIENT -- TO FOR
BREWERIES AND WINERIES TO REUSE
WATER -- ALTHOUGH THE TRAIL IS
TEMPORARILY OVER WE KNOW IT'S ON
MOVING OUT THERE WILL COME BACK
AND WE HAVE A SHORT TERM.
SENIOR LONG TERM STRUCTURAL
WATER SHORTAGES IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE MUST.
DO MORE WATER RE USE WE ARE
BEHIND -- SAID SB ONE SIXTY SIX
WILL DIRECT -- THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. TO GIVE
ME A WORKING GROUP AIMS ADVISING
THE LEGISLATURE ON THIS ISSUE --
ESTABLISHING A CLEAR CONSISTENT
WATER QUALITY STANDARDS FOR THE
RE USE OF PROCESS WATER.
ON SITE AND BREWERIES AND
WINERIES A RIGHT NOW IT TAKES ON
AVERAGE. FIVE TO SEVEN GALLONS
OF WATER. TO PRODUCE -- ONE
GALLON OF BEER -- WE CAN DO
BETTER AND WE NEED TO PROVIDE --
OUR PARTNERS IN THE INDUSTRY
WITH ALL THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO
DO WHAT THEY WANT TO DO -- WHICH
IS TO RE USE MORE OF THIS WATER --
THIS BILL RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
CAN BEING THAT -- STAKEHOLDER
GROUP WITH THE BOTH THE BEER AND
WINE INDUSTRIES -- OUR GOAL IS --
TO WHEN WE INTRODUCED A BILL IT
INITIALLY DIRECTED THE WATER
BOARD TO SET STANDARDS -- WE ALL
SHARE THE SAME GOALS BUT THERE
WAS A LITTLE BIT DISAGREED ON
HOW TO GET THERE.
SO WE AGREE TO REDUCE IT TO THIS
BILL AND WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH THE INDUSTRY -- TO BUILD IT
BACK OUT.
AND SO THAT'S WHERE WE ARE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY -- IS -- AS JASON
OCCURRED -- FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION HI MELISSA -- LOCKS
AND WITH AT HIGHS OR BUSH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JASON OCCURRED WITH
ADULTS TING GILBERT ROBESON
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCOPUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME.
AS CENTER SAID WE'RE JUST
LOOKING TO PUT TOOLS IN THE
HANDS OF THE THE WINE AND BEER
INDUSTRY IF THEY DO WANT TO YOU
REVIEWS PROCESS WATER ON SITE WE
THINK THAT'S A LOT OF THE GOAL.
A LOT OF LOCAL APPRECIATE THE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION THE SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN PERSONAL SIMILAR
ACCENT ANHEUSER BUSCH WE
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
AND HIS STAFF ON THIS BILL AND
THINK IT'S MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION -- IT'S A FANTASTIC
IDEA VAN NUYS WE RECYCLE NE
HUNDRED MILLION GALLONS A DAY OF
WATER ONLY ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THOSE GALLONS ARE
REUSABLE FOR US.
SO WE WE REALLY THINK THAT THIS
BILL WHAT WOULD HELP US -- TO
THAT IN SO PREPARE ABOUT THANK
YOU.
THIS BILL WOULD PUT.
I SHOULD ASK IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
NO OPPOSITION IS THERE FILED NO
FILE FILE ANY QUESTIONS I DID
HEAR MOTION.
MISTER WINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
QUESTION I'VE A WE HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WAS SUPPORT
ON BOTH SIDES PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO I'M
PORTANTINO AYE BATES.
BATES AYE BRADFORD.
HILL HILL AYE JONES.
JONES I WE CASKEY HI BECAUSE HE
AYE.
GONNA HOLD IT OPEN FOR MISTER
BRADFORD DISH FIVE VOTES RIGHT
NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT YOUR
COLLEAGUES -- WE NEED MISTER
MCGUIRE IS OUR LAST PRESENTER WE
WILL GO BACK -- TO IS GALGIANI
IS S. B. TO SIXTEEN ON AIR
QUALITY HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS -- ANY
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE -- ANY QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT BILL WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
NOW MISTER MCGUIRE HAS ONE BILL
THAT HE DID NOT WAY PRESENTATION
HE KNOWS IT'S GOING THE SUSPENSE.
BUT IT'S A DISTRICT ISSUE AND HE
WOULD LIKE -- TO BRIEFLY
PRESENTED TO US -- SO MISTER
MCGUIRE IF YOU COULD COME UP.
AND THEN SB THREE FIVE SIX ON
NORTH COAST RAILROAD AUTHORITY --
THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED PLEASE
PROCEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND GOOD MORNING MEMBERS YES SIR
WE ARE MOVING WE ARE WAITING ON
IT SB SIX SEVENTY AS WELL AS AS
BE.
SEVEN NINETY ONE PRESENT IN AN
SB -- THREE FIFTY SIX AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING US TO BE REPRESENTED A
DO APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS BY
YEAR INCREDIBLE TEAM THIS IS A
FOLLOW UP BILL TO LAST YEAR'S SB
TEN TWENTY NINE WHICH WAS
SUCCESSFUL.
THE INS YOU'RE A CLOSURE IN
TRANSITION ACT IT WAS SIGNED BY
THEN GOVERNOR BROWN SB TEN
TWENTY NINE SET UP A PROCESS TO
TRANSITION -- THREE PLUS MILE
MOSTLY DILAPIDATED IN LARGER
LARGE THE INOPERATIVE RAIL LINES
INTO A WORLD CLASS TRAVEL SYSTEM
THE RUN THROUGH SOME THE WILDEST
AND MOST SCENIC LANDSCAPES IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
TRACK IS LOCATED NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA RUNNING FROM HUMBOLDT
BAY ALL THE WAY DOWN TO SAN
FRANCISCO BAY IN MARIN COUNTY
THIS YEAR WE'VE BEEN INTRODUCED
SB THREE FIFTY SIX TO CONTINUE
THE INTERIOR SHUT DOWN.
BY PROPOSING TO TRANSFER THE
RAIL ASSETS FROM WILLITS SOUTH.
TO THE CINEMA MARIN AREA RAIL
TRANSIT AUTHORITY.
IT WILL ALSO PROVIDE FOR ONE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM IN HIS YOU
KNOW COUNTY ON THE SMART BOARD
OF DIRECTORS.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING
HARD ON THE YACHT IT'S AN
ASSESSMENT AND WE'RE GRATEFUL
FOR THAT WHICH WERE REQUIRED IN
SB.
TEN TWENTY NINE WE'LL WAIT FOR
THE COMPLETION BEFORE UTILIZING
THIS BILL TO IMPLEMENT THEIR
FINDINGS WITH SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION REGARDING THE FISCAL
ANALYSIS WILL BE WORKING WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF. TO BE A REDUCE
THE SCOPE AND POTENTIAL COSTA
DIGNIFIED AND WITH ME TODAY
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE THAT THE
MAN THE MYTH ALLEGING MISTY
WHILE LOOK.
WHO'S REPRESENTING SMART HE'S
VERY EXCITED TO BE HERE SIR --
AND WE DO AGAIN APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK ALONG WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF -- GOOD MORNING
STEVE ALL COME BACK THIS NUMBER
AND EVERY REAL TRANSIT DISTRICT
WE DO ORDER SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL AND HOPEFULLY AS IT MOVES
FORWARD WE WE WORK WITH THAT THE
STATE ON THE AUDITS IN THE SCOPE
OF THE WORK.
AND HOW THIS UP PROCESS WALKING
TOGETHER -- SMART OPERATES A
COMMUTER RAIL SERVICE RIGHT NOW
FROM SANTA ROSA DOWN -- TO
CENTER FELL AND SOON TO BE -- TO
THAT THE FERRY.
TERMINAL -- IN WORKSHOPS AND
LOOKS FOR THE AND THEN WE'RE
ALSO WORKING TO MOVE -- FOR FORD
WITHOUT MOVING SERVICE NORTH --
TO TO WINDSOR AND ALL ALL TOLD
ME UP TO CLOVERDALE BUT AS A SUB
PROJECT WAS FORWARD THAT MIGHT
BE -- MICHAEL FURTHER AT MAJOR
CENTER BUT WE DO RICHARD SUPPORT
TO MOVE THIS FORWARD AS WE CAN
WORK OUT THE DETAILS OF THAT THE
ASSETS AND LIABILITIES.
AND THE AND THE SCOPE OF THE
PROJECT.
RICHARD SUPPORT THANKS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION FINANCE THE FILE
NO FILE ANY QUESTIONS. FOR
MISTER MCGUIRE SING NO QUESTIONS
THIS IS THIS SUSPENSE.
MS BATES HAS A QUESTION FOR YOU
NOT SURE THAT I MIGHT HAVE
MISSED IT WHEN YOU'RE
PRESENTATIONS AND REQUIRE ABOUT.
THERE IF YOU ARE OF REQUEST
REMEMBERS FOR THE PROTOCOLS FOR
THE NOTIFICATION.
WHICH BY THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
[inaudible]
GROUP -- I THINK THAT WAS ON SB --
SIX SEVENTY FAR ON THE AVERAGE
BUILD BROWN BELT.
INTO BE HAPPY BETTER ADDRESS
THAT THROUGH THE CHAIR IF YOU
LIKE ON THAT BILL -- ISSUED SMIS
BATES ASKED THE QUESTION IF YOU
HAVE A GOOD ANSWER THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU A BETTER VICE CHAIR SO --
YES WE ARE -- WORKING WITH ALL
SIDES THAT INCLUDES -- THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ALONG WITH THE OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE ON THIS BILL -- THEY HAVE
PRESENTED SOME AMENDMENTS AND WE
ARE CONTINUE WORK THROUGH THEM
WE MET WITH HIM.
SEVERAL TIMES BOTH MYSELF
PERSONALLY AS WELL STAFF AND
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO MEET
WITH THEM GIVE IT A MOVE THIS.
FOR WE HAVE A SUPPORT ON THAT I
THINK IT SOUNDS LIKE A REALLY
GOOD.
NO ABSOLUTELY AND THERE.
NO I AM VERY IMPRESSED NO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND MINIMIZE CHAIR
AND WHAT I'LL SAY IS THAT
THEY'VE ALSO BEEN ENGAGING WITH
THE OFFICE OF BRING TO SERVICES
AS WELL -- FOR THE GREATER PART
OF SIX MONTHS ON A VERY SIMILAR
ISSUE AND TRYING TO BE A TO
BRING IT ALL TOGETHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER MCGUIRE WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE ON THREE FIFTY SIX AT
APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD AT
REQUEST SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FROM THOSE TO
BE HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE FIVE SIX WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
THAT IS OUR LAST -- SCHEDULED
PRESENTATION -- ALL THE BILLS
THAT HAVE BEEN PRESENTED AROUND
CALL WE ARE GOING TO GO TO SB
FIVE NINETY ONE BY MS GALGIANI.
ON INCARCERATED PERSONS HEALTH
RECORDS AS THEIR SUPPORT TEAR.
DROP POSITION FINANCE FILE NO
FILE SEEING NO.
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FIVE NINETY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE.
SB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT BY MS
GALGIANI FINANCIAL AID HOUSING
HUNGER HARDSHIPS -- IS THERE
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE SEEING
NO OBJECTIONS AND NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB.
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO MISTER
WINNERS -- SP ONE THIRTY TWO ON
CORRECTIONS.
YOUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
FILE NO FILE WITH OUT SEEING ANY
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB.
ONE THIRTY TWO WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB.
ONE FORTY FIVE BY MISTER WINNER
ON THE SEX OFFENDERS
REGISTRATION -- THEY ARE THERE
ANY SUPPORTERS AND THE OPPOSERS
IS THERE FILE FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ONE SIX A
TO ME -- ONE FOUR FIVE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE WE OF DISPENSED WITH
ONE SIX SIX AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON IT SB.
TWO EIGHTY FIVE BY MR WYNN ON
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES IS OUR
SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FILE FILE NO FILE
SIGNAL QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWO EIGHTY FIVE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO MS
JACKSON WHO GRACIOUSLY WAVED.
PRESENTATION -- WE APPRECIATE
THAT SB ONE THIRTY FIVE MS
JACKSON I'M PAID FAMILY LEAVE --
IS THERE ARE SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION IS THERE A FILE FILE.
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION ONE
THIRTY FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
SB TWO EIGHTY MISS JACKSON OLDER
ADULTS FALL PREVENTION.
THEIR SUPPORT.
COME ON UP.
GOOD MORNING BATTLE IN COOPER ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS ANY
OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE FILE NO
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO
EIGHTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB FIVE FIVE ONE MS JACKSON ON
THERE SUPPORT [inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
FILE FILE NO FILE MOVING ON TO
MS MITCHELL WHO GRACIOUSLY --
WAVE PRESENTATION ON HER ONE TWO
THREE FOUR BILLS SB ONE FOR FOR
CRIMINAL FEES IS THERE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION FINANCE A FILE NO
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION ONE FOUR
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB
THREE TWENTY ONE MS MITCHELL AND
CAL WORKS SERVICES CHILD CARE.
SIR SUPPORT THEIR OPPOSITION IS
THERE A FILE FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THREE TWENTY ONE WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB SIX FORTY SEVEN MS
MITCHELL.
A HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCE JEWELRY --
IS THEIR SUPPORT YOUR OPPOSITION.
NO FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB. SIX FORTY SEVEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB SEVEN
SIXTEEN MS MITCHELL JUVENILES
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SIRSUPPORT -- OPPOSITION THE
FILE THERE IS NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN SIXTEEN WE'LL
GO TO SUSPENSE MISTER WILK --
GRACIOUSLY WAVED HIS
PRESENTATION ON SB ONE FIFTY
THREE ON INDUSTRIAL HEMP --
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MICHAEL GREEN
CALIFORNIA STATE GRANGE STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE FINANCE THE FILE NO
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ONE
FIFTY THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB ONE SIXTY THREE PORTANTINO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENTS AS
THEIR SUPPORT YOUR OPPOSITION AS
OUR FILE THE FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION ONE SIXTY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPEND SAYS
PEACE.
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT PORTANTINO
COLLEGE FOCUS RE HOUSING PROGRAM.
IS THERE SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
THE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION FIVE SIXTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB SIX NINETY FIVE BY
PORTANTINO.
LAND USE HOUSING FOSTER YOUTH
SIR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION THE FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX NINETY
FIVE ABOUT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON A
MISTER MINING GRACIOUSLY WAVED.
PRESENTATION ON HIS TWO BILLS SP
ONE EIGHTY NINE ON FORT BOARD
REVIEW SYSTEM ALREADY IS THERE
SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION WE HAVE
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN NAMES
LANE LONG AND CITY MANAGER AT
THE CITY ROOM OF MARINA.
WE APPRECIATE THE HELP OF YOUR
STAFF AS WE WORK THROUGH THE
UNDERSTANDING THIS BILL.
AS WRITTEN WE CURRENTLY OPPOSE
IT WE ARE THE LARGEST LAND USE
JURISDICTION WORK THE FORMER
FORT ORD TILL LIVES WE HAVE
OVER SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
BLIGHTED MILITARY BERWICK STILL.
IN OUR COMMUNITY AS LONG AS FOR
CONTINUES AND IN ITS CURRENT
PATH -- THERE'S NO PENCILS
BERWICK'S TO GET REMOVED WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS SO WE OPPOSE
THE BILL'S CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
HOWEVER WERE CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH SENATORMONNING AND HIS
STAFF AND HOPE TO MAKE SOME
REVISIONS THAT WILL.
ADDRESS A BURKE CONCERNS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE NO FILE
NO FILE -- WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
ONE EIGHTY NINE WE'LL GO TO
SUSPEND SAYS BEFORE THIRTY THREE
ON YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND
DIVERSIONS BY MR MINING.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE NO
FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION FOR THIRTY
THREE VOTER SUSPENSE MISS
SKINNER HAS GRACIOUSLY WAVE
PRESENTATION ON HER THREE BILLS
SO FIRST ONE UP AS SB.
TWO OH SIX ON ATHLETICS FAIR PAY
TO PLAY.
THEIR SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
BUT SIR OTHERS IN SUPPORTERS ARE
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE FINANCE THE FILE NO
FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO OH SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AS BEFORE
SEVENTY MISS SKINNER ELECTRONIC
BENEFITS TRANSFER SYSTEM.
THEIR SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION SIR
FILE FILE NO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AS BEFORE
SEVENTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB
FIVE SIXTEEN MY MISS SKINNER.
EVIDENCE STREET GANG
PARTICIPATION THEIR SUPPORT AS
OUR OPPOSITION.
FINANCIAL FILE FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE SIXTEEN WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
MISTER BELL GRACIOUSLY WAY
PRESENTATION ON SB TWO EIGHTY
TWO SIR SUPPORT PRESS BE TWO
EIGHTY TWO ONE SUPPORT OF
HOUSING FOR PAROLEES.
SIR OPPOSITION FINANCE SO FILE
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO
EIGHTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MR ARCHER LETTER WAY
PRESENTATION SB TWO EIGHTY NINE
ON MEDI CAL MILITARY ANSWER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
THE FILE NO FILE SB TWO EIGHTY
NINE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
SB FIVE EIGHT EIGHT MISTRUST
FROM OTHER DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESS PROGRAMS.
YOUR SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FILE YES WE'VE FILE
WE HAVE A FILE THE A A FINANCES
ACTION NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL.
WE KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES ESTIMATES --
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE ONE TIME
COST OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A TO DEVELOP THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES TO
COMPLY WITH THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS -- ADDITIONALLY TGS
ANTICIPATES ANNUAL COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE SERVICE
REVOLVING FUND -- INCLUDING FOR
POSITIONS TO REVIEW AND
INVESTIGATE CASES MANAGE THE
SUSPENSION PROCESS AND TO
CONDUCT ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS.
ANY QUESTIONS SEEINGNO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FIVE EIGHT EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPEND.
PAGE ONE IS DONE PAGE TWO MISTER
ROTH GENERAL ROTH IS GRACIOUSLY
WAY PRESENTATION ON HIS TWO
BILLS SB THREE OH SEVEN WATER
FACILITY WITH UNUSED CAPACITY IS
THEIR SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION IS THERE FILE FILE
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THREE OH SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB.
SIX FIVE FIVE BY GENERAL ROTH ON
PHARMACY IS THERE ARE SUPPORT
SIR OPPOSITION.
THE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SIX FIVE FIVE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE.
MR HERTZBERG HAS WAY
PRESENTATION SB THREE FIFTEEN
GOBIZ PROMISE ZONES.
IS THERE SUPPORT ANSWER
OPPOSITION.
NO FILE AND WITHOUT OBJECTION --
THREE FIFTEEN ORDER SUSPENSE
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
WE WILL GO TO MISTER ROGERS WHO
HAS GRACIOUSLY WAY PRESENTATION
SB.
THREE FIVE FOUR ON CALIFORNIA
DREAM LOAN PROGRAM IS THEIR
SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER SISTER OPPOSITION.
FINANCE NO FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE FIFTY FOUR
WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE.
SB SIX TWENTY TWO MITTERRAND'S
ON CIVIL DETENTION FACILITIES
HAS THEIR SUPPORT.
MORE MAPS MISTER CHAIR RIGHT
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
SIR OPPOSITION.
SIR FIVE THE FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB.
SIX TWO TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WE'VE DONE THREE FIFTY SIX BY MR
REQUIRE WE'RE MOVING ON TO SIX
SEVENTY TELECOMMUNICATIONS
OUTAGES.
WE HAD A QUESTION IT WAS
ANSWERED.
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT GO AHEAD GOOD
MORNING CARE AWESOME BEHALF THE
CITY OF SANTA ROSA IN THE MARIN
COUNTY COUNCIL MAYORS AND
COUNCIL MEMBERS AND SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MATALIN COOPER ON BEHALF OF
MARIN COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION.
FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE --
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX SEVENTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB.
SEVEN NINETY ONE THE GOVERNOR
VINCE AND FINANCE BILL ON
TAXATION CERTIFICATION AIRCRAFT --
IS THEIR SUPPORT.
FILE NEW FILE NO FIVE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN NINETY ONE
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
SB THREE SIXTY FOUR MISTER STONE
IS WAIVED PRESENTATION ON HIS
BILLS WE APPRECIATE THAT SB
THREE SIXTY FOUR ON PROPERTY
TAXATION VETERANS.
THEIR SUPPORT. FOR OPPOSITION
FINANCE THE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION THREE SIXTY FOUR WE'RE
GONNA SUSPENSE AS BEFORE TWELVE
MR STONE ON DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES FEES. FOR SUPPORT.
SHOPPERS ISSHIN.
SIR FILE FILE NO FIRE WITHOUT
OBJECTION FOR TWELVE AGO TO
SUSPENSE.
SB FIVE NINETY BY MR STONE AND
MENTAL HEALTH EVALUATIONS
ALCOHOLISM IS THEIR SUPPORT.
THROUGHOUT POSITION.
NO FILE ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE NINETY WITH
OTHER SUSPENSE SB SIX EIGHTEEN
STONE PEACE OFFICERS PERJURY.
IS THERE SUPPORT -- OPPOSITION.
SIR FILE NEW FILE NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SIX EIGHTEEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MISTER GLAZIER IS GRACIOUSLY WAY
PRESENTATION ON IS ONE TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE SIX BILLS.
SB THREE SEVENTY FOUR CAL WORKS
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION SIR
SUPPORT [inaudible]
PROPOSITION.
MR FILE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION THREE SEVENTY FOUR
WHEELER SUSPENSE SB SIX OH SIX
MR GLAZER ON CEMETERY IN
FUNERALS.
SIR SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION.
THE FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SIX OF SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB.
SIX OH SEVEN MR GLAZER ON
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY SIR
SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FINANCING FILED NO
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SIX OH
SEVEN WILL FOLLOW SIX OH SIX THE
SUSPENSE.
SB SIX TEN GLAZER CONTRACTORS
LICENSING AND REGULATION.
YOU'RE MOVING TO OKAY A SUPPORT
THERE WE GO.
GOOD MORNING MY CHEN NETSKY FOR
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD WE JUST WANTED -- TO
INFORM ME CHAIR AN HONORABLE
MEMBERS MEMBERS THAT THE BOARD
HAS BEEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
A FORMAL SUPPORT BUT WE
ANTICIPATE THAT IN CHEN.
SUCH FORTHCOMING AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION SING
NINE FINANCING FILE NO FILE.
SB SIX TEN WILL FOLLOW SB SIX OH
SEVEN TWO SUSPENSE.
I WITHOUT OBJECTIONSB -- SIX
THIRTY FOUR GLAZER ON EDUCATION --
THEIR SUPPORT FOR SIX THIRTY FOR
OPPOSITION FINANCE THE FILE.
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX
THIRTY FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN MY MISTER
GLAZER.
ON ALAMEDA TESLA EXPANSION AREA
IS THERE SUPPORT.
THEIR OPPOSITION YEAH I SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT COME TELL US.
MISTER CHAIR AMY GRANTED ON
BEHALF OF THE OFF ROAD VEHICLE
LEGISLATIVE COALITION.
THE SUGGESTED MARKET VALUE SALE
WILL NOT MAKE STATE PARKS HOLE
OR ENABLE ACQUISITION OF
ALTERNATIVE PLAN THE WHICH WE
TRUST FUND ALSO PAID MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR PLANNING AN
ENVIRONMENTAL REPORTS.
ADDITIONALLY USING LEGISLATIVE
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS A LOCAL
NAME THE ISSUE IS NOT FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JEFF PUT A CALIFORNIA FOUR WHEEL
DRIVE ASSOCIATION.
WE OPPOSE THE SB.
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN KEN CLARK
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA OFF ROAD
VEHICLE ASSOCIATION AND THE
WONDER OF WANDERING WHEELERS OF
HAYWARD CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE
THIS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHERS
SEEING NO OTHER HANDS.
IS FINANCE HAVE A FILE NO FILE
NO FILE -- SEEING THEIR
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN OR GO TO SUSPEND.
WE'VE DONE THIS BEFORE -- TO BY
MISTER PORTER GOSS WE'RE GONNA
GO TO AS BEFORE -- FOR BY MISS
CHIANG WHO GRACIOUSLY WAY
PRESENTATION THIS IS ON CHINO
HILLS STATE PARK EXPANSION SIR
SUPPORT THEIR OPPOSITION.
NO FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AS BEFORE -- FOR WATER
SUSPENSE -- MADAM PRO TEM IS
ATKINS HAS TWO BILLS WHICH SHE'S
GRACIOUSLY WAY PRESENTATION.
SB FOUR FIVE ONE INCOME TAX
HISTORIC STRUCTURES SIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION.
NO FILE NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP FOUR FIVE ONE WE GO
TO SUSPENSE SB FIVE OH SEVEN MY
MISS ACTIONS ON THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED PORT.
DISTRICT -- SEEING NO SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE
FILE NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB.
FIVE OH SEVEN WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MS BATES GRACIOUSLY WAY
PRESENTATION NEXT BEFORE SIXTY
FIVE ON SEVEN OFFERING NUCLEAR.
GENERATING STATION IS HER
SUPPORT.
PROPOSITION IS THERE FILE FILE
THERE IS NO FIL MS BATES IS
FOUR SIX FIVE FOUR VOTER
SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MISTER STERN AWAY PRESENTATION
ON HABITAT CONSERVATION FINEST
BEFORE.
SEVEN FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION IS THERE FILE
FILE.
YOU KNOW FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION
IS BEFORE.
SEVEN FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
AS COMMITTEE BILL SB SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE ON PUBLIC RESOURCES
IS THERE ANY SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FINANCIAL FILED NO
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE.
MR TACOS FIRST BILL SB FOUR NINE
EIGHT SHE WAVED GRACIOUSLY WAY
PRESENTATION AS BEFORE NINE
EIGHT ON SHORT LINE RAILROADS
GRANT PROGRAMS OR SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION FINANCE THE FILE NO
FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AS BEFORE
NINETY EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WE HAVE -- DEALT WITH FIVE FIVE
NINE RIGHT WITH WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT WENT TO SUSPENSE.
FOR MOVING ON TO WE'VE DEALT
WITH FIVE OH SIX BY MR HUESO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO HIS OTHER
TWO BILLS WHICH SHE GRACIOUSLY.
WAY PRESENTATION SB SEVEN
NINETEEN MR HUESO VETERANS STATE
PARK FEES.
AND EXPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION FINANCE THE FILE
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SEVEN NINETEEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
MISTER HUESO CALIFORNIA MEXICO
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS.
SIR SUPPORT DROP POSITION IS --
FILE FILE.
NO FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE MISTER BRADFORD.
HAS THREE BILLS AND WE ARE.
TRACKING HIM DOWN RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER BRADFORD HAS
THREE BILLS -- WHICH SHE WAY
PRESENTATION SB FIVE NINETEEN
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCE STORAGE
TANKS -- SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE SB FIVE NINETEEN
GODDESSES FRANCIS BE SEVEN
THIRTY ONE MISTER BRADFORD
WORKERS COMPENSATION RISK
FACTORS.
SIR OPPOSITION FINANCE I THINK I
SKIP TO THE LAST TIME DID NOT
HAVE NO MORE FILES NO MORE FILES
OKAY.
SB.
FIVE SEVEN THIRTY ONE WE'LL GO
TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SEVEN SEVENTY TWO MISTER
BRADFORD.
LONG DURATION BALK ENERGY
STORAGE.
THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
WHICH CHAIR MEMBERS GREG COOK
WAS A NO THE CALIFORNIA POWER
AGENCY AS YOUR ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT.
THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT COST INCREASE TO ALL
RATEPAYERS INCLUDING THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
BLUEPRINT PROCESS AT THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE PROVISION
OF ELECTRIC SERVICE IS ON THE
LAWN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
OVER 90% OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE CHOSEN TO TRANSFER THAT
REPLICATION TO INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES HOWEVER THOSE FORTY
PLUS CITIES.
THAT HAVE RETAINED THAT
RESPONSIBILITY ARE RESPONSIBLE --
FOR FOR THE PROVISION OF
ELECTRIC SERVICE AND RELIABILITY
SO THIS IS BILL WOULD BE
CONTRARY TO THE STATE
CONSTITUTION IN THAT REGARD.
IN ADDITION THIS BILL IS
CONTRARY TO THE INTENT OF THE
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR WHAT
WAS TO STAB WISHED IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE INDEPENDENT.
OF ANY GENERATION RESOURCES THIS
BILL WOULD VIOLATE THAT
REQUIREMENT WE URGE A NO VOTE ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN THE OPPOSITION.
NO MORE FILE SUCH SOUNDS LIKE A
SONG NO MORE FILES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN SEVEN TWO
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE WE OF
DISPENSED WITH SB FIVE FORTY
THREE BY DOCTOR PAN.
REMOVE ON TO MISTER HILL WHO A
PRESENTATION ON HIS BILL -- FIVE
FIVE ZERO SIR SUPPORT ON PUBLIC
UTILITIES MISTER HILL.
OPPOSITION NOW FILE WE KNOW
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE FIVE
ZERO WE GOT A SUSPENSE MR MORALE
GRACIOUSLY WAY PRESENTATION ON
SB FIVE SIXTY TWO WHICH PROPERTY
TAXATION OF VETERANS.
THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
NO FILE -- WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FIVE SIXTY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPEND.
MR UMBERG GRACIOUSLY WAY
PRESENTATION ON HIS TWO BILLS SB
FIVE NINETY THREE LICENSE PLATES
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS.
THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE NO FILE THAT OBJECTION SB
FIVE NINETY THREE WE'RE GONNA
SUSPENSE SB SEVEN THIRTY SIX BY
MYSTERON BURKE ON CREATIVE
ECONOMY TASKFORCE -- THIS OR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION NO FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SEVEN THIRTY
SIX WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
MS RUBIO GRACIOUSLY WENT
PRESENTATION SB FIVE NINETY FOUR
ENGLISH LEARNER ROAD MAP
INITIATIVE.
IS THERE SUPPORT THEIR
OPPOSITION WE KNOW THERE'S NO
FILE THAT OBJECTION.
SB FIVE NINETY FOUR WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN MY
MAYES RUBIO HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING.
SIR SUPPORT THEIR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
GO TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MISTER MOORE LIKE GRACIOUSLY WAY
PRESENTATION ON SB.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT OPEN FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS ACT AS THEIR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
PROPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WE WILL SEND SB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION -- IS CAVALIER WAY
PRESENTATION ON SIX ELEVEN ON
HOUSING ELDERLY AND DISABLED
THEIR SUPPORT FOR SIX ELEVEN IS
THEIR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WITHOUT OBJECTION B
SIX ELEVEN WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
MISTER ALLEN GRACIOUSLY WAY
PRESENTATION ON CLIMATE
ACCOUNTABILITY PROTOCOL SB SIX
EIGHTY TWO SIR SUPPORT.
SIR OPPOSITION SEEING NONE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX EIGHTY
TWO ABOUT A SUSPENSE AND FINALLY
MS LEYVA GRACIOUSLY WAY
PRESENTATION SB.
SIX NINETY EIGHT ON EMPLOYEE
WAGES -- THEIR SUPPORT IS YOUR
OPPOSITION.
YOU KNOW THERE'S NO FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SIX NINETY EIGHT
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE.
THAT TAKES CARE OF ALL OUR
BUSINESS MISTER JONES YOU MISSED
A COUPLE VOTES.
SO WE LIFT THE CALLS ON THOSE
AND I THINK YOU CAN GO AFTER
THAT OKAY SO IF WE COULD GO
THROUGH THE BILL'S.
MISTER JONES MR SO WE CAN GET
HIM ON HIS WAY.
AND YOU KNOW WHICH ONES THEY ARE
I DON'T.
SB SIXTY TWO DODD THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
BRADFORD.
JONES.
JONES HI.
SO THAT'S FIVE ZERO KEEP THAT ON
CALL.
SB.
FOUR FOUR TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
BRADFORD JONES JONES II.
THAT'S FIVE ZERO KEEP THAT ON
CALL.
YOU WERE HERE FOR EVERYTHING
ELSE SO THOSE YEAR.
TO HELP KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
FOR MISTER BRADFORD WE HAVE ANY
TA.
THE TO ME EARLIER [inaudible]
OKAY
GO THROUGH ONE LAST TIME.
SB [inaudible]
SIXTY TWO BRADFORD.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FIVE ZERO SB [inaudible]
FOUR FOUR TWO BRADFORD.
BUT BILLS OUT.
FIVE ZERO SB.
ONE SIX SIX BRADFORD THE BILL IS
OUT.
FIVE ZERO SB FOUR OH TWO
BRADFORD.
WE CAL SKI.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
FORTY ZERO SB FIVE OH SIX
BRADFORD.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FIVE ZERO SB SB FIVE FOUR THREE
BRADFORD.
POPULOUS OUT.
FIVE ZERO THAT INCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS TODAY.
THIS MANY JOURNAL